hello hi everyone
welcome to our um aws hiking phase
workshop on how to accelerate bird
inference and we are going to wait a few
more minutes until
people will join
maybe what's quite interesting for me
would be to know where are you currently
and have you used stage maker before
people are typing atlanta awesome yes
nice that's great to hear yes
brazil
chicago india
cool
that's a lot of messages spain
mumbai
pc
wow
wow
well what time is it currently in india
isn't it like already 11 in the evening
or something 10 30 i guess
yeah
9 30. wow
i'm 9 30.
wow so thank you for being so dedicated
i'm not sure i would want to listen to
sagemaker talks at 9 30.
midnight in singapore
that's crazy yeah so we are going to
record the event
and we'll publish it to the hanging face
youtube account afterwards so if you
cannot like listen the full hour or
need to like move to another meeting or
have something else to do you can like
easily look up what we have done on
youtube or also like do it a second time
[Music]
yeah we will share the youtube link on
social media
um
and in the forum so just keep an eye on
it and you will find it
should we share the form link now
yeah i think yeah you can share it
already
so
for those who have worked with fighting
first before and maybe for the new ones
so we have a nice
big community forum where you can like
ask all tons of questions about amazon
search maker hugging face about the
things we will do in the workshop also
about things we are not doing in the
workshop just out of curio curiosity you
can like
ask us anything
and lewis should
send
link anytime soon
awesome i think yeah let's wait two more
minutes for people to chime in we are
already at 218 which is like super
crazy amazing thank you everyone for
coming exciting time
[Music]
working late
yeah carlos it's
it's going to be recorded and shared on
the hugging face youtube channel
so one more minute
last chance for people to get started
yeah it's not
that much important if you have search
maker experience or not this workshop is
not mostly about sagemaker it's also
about like how to work with fighting
phase transformers how to apply
knowledge distillation
and uh we will use stage maker uh in the
exam like in the workshop to deploy a
model to sagemaker for real-time
inference where you can send your
requests to the model
but um yeah you i think you can easily
get through the workshop without much
stage maker experience and if you
afterwards like to get more uh like to
know more about sagemaker we have done a
few more workshops in the past um to get
it started you can also find them on
the github repository we will share in a
minute and on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
uh yes we will be taking questions at
the end but you can just leave any
questions in the chat and also
um we'll interrupt each other
yeah and sir
yeah maybe in the future there will be
something for gcp but currently i have
no idea what the future will bring so
hopefully who knows
and yeah so i think we can get started
so welcome again for everyone who joins
from india singapore to us and europe
and today we will focus on how to
accelerate bird inference with knowledge
distillation and aws inferentia
and
me joining is lewis who is a machine
learning engineer and also the author of
the
newly transformers book natural language
processing with transformers and also
joined by aws's haiku who is an aiml
solution senior solution architect and
i'm phillip i'm a technical lead at
hiking space so welcome from from our
side
and what we are going to do so the
workshop consists out of three different
labs the first level is fine tuning a
large transformer model with amazon
stage maker we are going to skip this
part since we only have 75 minutes and
want to really focus on the knowledge
distillation and acceleration part with
aws neuron but you can like re-run the
training with stage maker after the
workshop or tomorrow or whenever you
have time lap two will be making models
smaller with novice distillation this
will be a deep dive by lewis really
showing you okay how can i apply
knowledge distillation to transformer
models how would i select my teacher how
can i select my student or what's really
important to look after for doing
knowledge distillation and lab three
will be the hands-on part where you will
get access to temporary aws accounts and
where we will convert a hiking phase
transformer model with the aws nylon sdk
and then deploy it to sagemaker for
real-time inference achieving super low
latency and what this
means in terms of numbers we will
basically lab one fine students a
roberta larch model on the clink or oos
data set which is an intent
classification data set achieving 1979
accuracy then we will distill it to a
mini lm achieving 94 accuracy and then
we will convert and compile it to aws
neuron which will still be close to 94
accuracy
and in terms of latency numbers we will
go from over 300 milliseconds to six
milliseconds per inference on a
sequence length of 128.
also um for you to get help we have a
huge discord you can join it you can ask
questions about hugging fails about
transformers you can share ideas
projects we also have the forum which
who is already shared and then there's
the github repository where all of the
code for the workshop will be stored you
can open issues if you have questions
and we are happy to help you
okay
first of all i'll hand over to haiko who
will give you a high level overview
about amazon ai and sagemaker
all right um
let me just share my screen
right
you're able to see my screen
excellent
hi and welcome everyone um this is going
to be brief i don't want to bore you too
much with slides
but
just a very brief overview of of
sagemaker
and and what it is and i like always to
think about it um
starting from the machine learning life
cycle meaning you know you start at the
top with accessing uh your data cleaning
your data and then preparing your data
uh then you build models which you then
train and evaluate
you deploy a model you monitor it at
some point you find out you know you
have some
model drift and
that means the whole cycle starts again
because you might have new data uh which
you have to clean prepare train your
model and deploy again
and um that's basically uh what we're
trying to do here at aws with um
sagemaker to give you a a suite of tools
um that lets you do all these steps
uh within
well within machine one machine learning
platform so as you can see on the top
we have the different stages again
preparing building training and
deploying your models
and then
in the columns you have the different
services that we offer within sagemaker
to help you get um
like do all these things within the
machine learning life cycle
so um today for example we're going to
be focusing uh lewis is going to be
focusing on training
[Music]
models and then in the hands-on session
with philip we're going to be deploying
models
to a real-time endpoint
in in sagemaker
and speaking of the deployment uh just a
quick overview on aws inferentia and
these uh inf1 instances that amazon has
developed for
machine learning inference
they're not gpu instances gpu instances
are usually not
mostly not the right
instances for inference
oftentimes if you if you aim to
to use gpu instances they're my most of
the time underutilized and that's why
aws created this inferential chip
with a much lower cost and
higher
or lower latency
as well
and the idea here is really
that you have these neuron cores
on
on
on the chip
and
the the neuron cone is the is the custom
accelerator and each inferential chip
comes with four of those
neuron cores and that enables you then
to either load one model
on each core or
four for higher throughput or one model
across all cores for lower latency
in terms of what that looks like then
with performance and cost
is um
that we have a
up to a 2.74 times higher throughput
than the g4 gpu instances on aws
also we are
delivering those inferences
with a cost savings of up to
68
uh compared for example to the g5
instances
um
that's really it from eyesight just to
give you a brief overview of like what
we what we're going to be covering today
the question question we had from the
chat is how does an inferential
deployment cost compared to deploying on
an aws london now that there's a 10
gigabyte accessible storage layer
so um different use cases we have if i
um go
can i quickly go back to the slide where
i have the deployments
on the right hand column in sagemaker um
there's different use cases um so we
have multimodal endpoints we have um
uh real-time endpoints we have
asynchronous and we also have serverless
endpoints um and and and there are
different use cases for each one of
those up until recently
the the serverless endpoints who are
like that are based on lambda
those were primarily used for smaller
models where you have infrequent
inference requests
whereas inferentia you would use in a
scenario in an application where you
need super low latency real time
inference requests and lots of them
at the same time
so
and then you have asynchronous which is
again for a different use case it's
where you need
near real-time inference but the
inference sometimes because these
language models can get really large
inference can sometimes take a minute or
two and when it's not critical that you
have it in like a millisecond
then um that's where we recommend the
asynchronous endpoint so it's not like
you can compare them apples to apples if
that makes sense you always got to think
about what is your use case and do i
need
um
what do i want to prioritize low latency
accuracy
cost and so on there's no
one-size-fits-all hope that makes sense
great again then we can get started with
our deep dive on how to do knowledge
distillation we will try to answer all
of your questions either like directly
with the person who is like currently
doing the session or answering in the
chat we definitely won't skip any
question you ask and to quickly answer
um kirtika's question is can you can we
use inferential to deploy our own
fine-tuned transformer yes we can and
that's basically what we are going to do
later
awesome thanks so
basically what i'm going to do here is
try to give you
a kind of high level picture of
what knowledge distillation is
and how we can actually implement this
for transformers
using sagemaker
so um in the next sessions um
i think haiku will show you how to set
up aws sagemaker but um basically all of
this is coming from this really nice
github repository that philip has
created for sagemaker and we're working
in workshop four
where we have these three different labs
so
lab one we're not going to go through
today but this is basically where we
train a large reverter model
and then in lab two which is what i'm
going to cover this is where we actually
take this large model and we can set it
into a smaller model
and lab three is what philip is going to
show us later where we take that
compressed model and then we
apply these fancy
optimization techniques um
within furniture and we get um some much
much
nice or much nicer compression and speed
okay so i'm not going to show you how to
clone the repo and set up your sagemaker
account
but basically once you do that you'll
end up with a kind of jupiter instance
like this where you'll see these three
notebooks and so if you click on the
knowledge distillation notebook you'll
get something like um like this
which has a bunch of text that explains
how this works and we'll go through that
together
um but at this stage what i want to sort
of just tell you is um for knowledge
distillation um the main concept is that
we have kind of two models
there's a teacher model which is the
large model
which is a very high performing model
and we have a student model which is
typically much smaller and that's the
thing that we want to somehow
give the information from the teacher
and make it perform better than just if
we fine-tune the student from scratch
so the kind of picture
that you typically see is that you have
these two models kind of working in
tandem and you have a way of kind of
measuring
how well the student is able to kind of
mimic the predictions of the teacher and
i'll go in these details in a bit
but um what i just wanted to say is just
this is the cartoon we'll go into it
and the the code itself is relatively um
simple especially in sagemaker so
the main thing you need to do is just
install um some basic packages that we
need
and then what we're going to do in this
notebook
is we're actually going to push
the models that we train
with knowledge distillation to the
hugging face hub under your account
so if you don't have a hug and face
account you just can go to hf dot co or
hugging face dot co and then you can
sign up
and once you have an account you'll get
something like this which is kind of
like a
feed of different activity
and when you want to basically provide
credentials to sagemaker so that it can
associate the model that you've trained
to your account
you just need to basically hit this
mobile login cell and provide a token
now these tokens are pretty similar to
other platforms you basically have
tokens that control what you can read
and write from
and you'll find your tokens under your
user account if you go basically on this
little profile icon go to settings
and here if you go down to access tokens
you can basically
pick an existing token
or you can also just create a new token
if you want so here i've got a token
that i have for workshops so i'm just
going to copy that by clicking here
and then when i feed this into this
little widget it will then authenticate
um
my sagemaker instance so that then
anything that i basically train
i can then push to my account
okay so
i'm just going to go through this code
very quickly and then we'll go back to
the kind of theory and the concepts just
because it takes around 10 minutes to
sort of train the model
so here there's a little bit of
configuration associated with sagemaker
which is just going to tell us something
about this
session that we're running and in
particular which kind of s3 bucket we're
going to be using to ultimately um store
the model to
so this is this if you've never seen
sagemaker this is kind of just some
boilerplate that just allows us to kind
of configure the session for the current
role we have and so here you can see you
know i have
some amazon roll we're on this bucket on
us east and we're in this region so this
will be different when you're running
this
with the
hashes that we provide for you but in
general it's just some basic for the
plate
okay so i'll skip this for now and come
back to in a sec
um
now
the basic thing that i was mentioning
for knowledge distillation is we have a
teacher model and a student model and
we're going to somehow take the
knowledge of the teacher and compress it
into the student
so here's a model that we've trained
earlier which is this roberta large
fine-tuned model
on a particular data set and the kind of
use case that we thought would be
interesting to showcase today
is something called intent
classification
and intent classification is a kind of
text classification um where you're
trying to basically understand if a
snippet of text is revealing some
specific intent
from a user
so the data set that we've used
for this
is called
the the clink 150 data set
and
this is a data set um where you've
basically
got text that represents kind of like
the type of
queries you might get um in a chatbot
and so the idea is like imagine that i i
type into some app what is my balance
then the classifier has to work out okay
i'm asking about balance this is
probably something about an account and
then you can provide you know some
information about that account um but
the problem is that like
if if you've ever built a chatbot or
anything that's kind of conversational
you know that like there are these kind
of like um turns in the in the
conversation where people may ask things
that are completely out of scope
so you can see in this example here that
after asking you know what is my
balance
someone might say oh how are my sports
teams doing
and here if your model has never seen
an intent that represents anything about
sport
it may get basically confused and just
give you some kind of garbage result
that okay you know something about your
payday
so this data set is kind of interesting
it basically has
a whole list of intents there's 150
different intents
and it also has out of scope intents
which means that you know doing well in
this data set
for these models is is often quite
tricky because you need to be able to
predict things that you haven't really
seen
and you can find this data set on the
hub it's called uh clink underscore oos
and you can see here some examples
of like you know can you walk me through
setting up direct deposits um and i
guess these are all direct deposit but
i'll let you um i'll put this in the
chat and you know you can
have a look and see what the data that
we're dealing with
okay so
that's the task so text classification
or intent classification and we've
already trained this revert to large
model
which i'll associate here
and this revert to large model um
gets quite good performance
um on this data set it gets an accuracy
of around 97
and the classes are roughly balanced so
that's not um
not such a misleading score
um and this is the kind of situation
that you'll typically experience in
industry where you
if you want to really maximize for
performance you'll typically pick a
large model because you know the larger
models have more capacity they typically
score higher
but then if you say okay now i want to
deploy this model into a production
setting i kind of have a problem because
these large models will typically take
you know
several hundreds of milliseconds to
generate a prediction and if you're
building a kind of application that has
these um these you know dialogues
between a customer and your your
your chatbot then this is you know far
too slow for the average user
so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this large model and we're going to
basically compress it into a smaller
model
and the model that we've picked today
is
a variant of what's called mini lm
so
basically if you're using the hugging
face hub almost everyone is using kind
of burt or distilbert
and these models are generally great for
starting with but obviously the field
evolves over time and mini lm is really
probably you know the state of the art
model in terms of doing something fast
and getting good results
so it's kind of like distilled but you
know a little bit better
and this particular model is it's a
pre-trained checkpoint so this is a
model that one of our colleagues at
hugging face has actually distilled
himself
using a technique we'll mention the sec
from a roberto large model but at this
stage it's only a pre-trained model so
it has no
it has no head that represents text
classification and in particular it has
no knowledge about
this clink
intent classification data set so what
we need to do is basically do a form of
fine tuning but during the fine-tuning
process we're going to augment the
signal that comes from the labels of the
of the data set with another signal
that's coming from the teacher which is
this roberto large model
okay so
basically that's what i've done here
i've just got these two
hyper parameters which say which is my
teacher checkpoint which is my student
checkpoint here we specified
what is the
data set that we're dealing with
so this particular data set has a bunch
of different subsets and i've picked one
called the plus subset which just has a
few more of these out of scope
examples
and then we're going to train for 10
epochs
and we've picked um there are a couple
of hyper parameters which i'll explain
um shortly um one of them is called the
temperature which if you're familiar
with um generative modeling that's um a
pretty common one and there's another
one called alpha which i'll explain
shortly and we we kind of figured out
which parameters were good doing some
hyper parameter optimization previously
but you know later you can also run your
own optimization if you want to find
different values for example if you're
using different models
and then we have some
kind of key arguments that we provide so
push to hub here will say okay at the
end of my training i want to push this
model to the huge face hub and in
particular this is the id that i will
expect to see this model under my
account
and we have a job name for sagemaker
and basically then that's it we just now
have this hugging face estimator
object so
if you're
not familiar with sagemaker if it's the
first time you're seeing this you can
think of this as
very similar to the trainer in
transformers it's kind of just a wrapper
around all of the logic that we need for
training
but it has some like extra
things that we can configure for example
we can specify what instance type we
want to do our training on
we can specify what transformers version
what pi torch version python versions
we can also specify a script that will
be executed on that instance so this is
really kind of like a meta trainer
because the actual training itself will
be inside this script and we'll go
through that logic um shortly
so i'm just going to run this
um and then once you've basically
configured your hugging face estimator
um you don't have to really do much
except run hugging face estimator.fit
um and there's a the main parameter you
need to maybe think about is weight
whether this is true or false so if we
set this parameter to true it will
basically store all the logs in the
notebook itself so this is kind of
closer to the experience that you may
have from
you know coding in notebooks generally
but what i'm going to do is i'm going to
set it to false because it actually will
store in the logs my token on the hub
and then you know suddenly you can
basically get access to all of my
repositories and i don't want that
happen
so i'm just going to run this
and what this is done now
we're using at the moment a sagemaker
instance which has only got a cpu but
what we've done is we've now launched a
job on a gpu machine so one of these p3
2x large machines
and you can inspect
these trainings by going to your
sagemaker console and then you'll see in
the training jobs here we've now
launched
a new knowledge distillation job and
this is in progress at the moment
so this is now going to take probably 10
minutes or so
to run
and so what i'm going to do now is i'm
actually going to explain how knowledge
distillation works
and some of the sort of technical
details of what's really happening under
the hood
um but before i do that are there any
questions right now yes there's the
question by ottoman we hope i hope i
pronounced it correctly um well if you
already also asked the same question are
we like using a distilled model and
distilling it again or are we
fine-tuning the digital mini lm model
yeah that's a great great question so
i'll um i think the way to answer that
is by is with a picture
and this this will be a nice kind of
segue into um what we're going to cover
so when we talk about knowledge
distillation um as i mentioned at the
very start there's this concept of two
models there's a teacher model which is
typically the big model and a student
which is a smaller model
and there are kind of two different ways
that people traditionally
convert or transfer the knowledge
so if you're doing something called task
specific distillation which is what
we're doing today
the basic idea is that you have this
teacher
you have a student
and at the start
this teacher is already fine-tuned
on the task that you care about so this
is for example the roberta model that i
showed you before that has been
fine-tuned on clink
and then what we do is we um take a
student model that is just a pre-trained
model and then we're going to do
fine-tuning with this distillation
signal so it's kind of like the standard
fine-tuning that you do all the time but
we have an additional signal coming from
the teacher which i'll show you shortly
how that works
now in this particular case we chose for
the student
a model
which is called mini lm blah blah blah
distilled from roberto large
so this is actually already a distilled
model kind of like the steel bird
but the way this was created was using
what's called task agnostic distillation
so the idea here is you take a teacher
model
and you have a student
and you basically just do the
distillation procedure
as part of your pre-training so at this
stage there's no concept of
task-specific heads you're just doing
pre-training and that's a slightly
different type of distillation that we
won't do today but it's often the one
that produces
many of the models that you'll see on
the hub like the steel bur amino
and i just we just picked this
particular mini lm variant because it's
already quite small and quite fast um so
that has look like the kind of
properties that we want to start with
another question from giovanni is should
the teacher and the student share the
same architecture
yeah that's a great question so
um i'm going to share a link or i'll put
this in the chat so basically there's a
fantastic paper by microsoft
called um fast formers
and they did a very extensive analysis
of knowledge distillation
and what they
point out
is that in their experiments
distillation typically doesn't work
when the
teacher and the student have basically
different architectures or different
vocabularies is probably the better way
of putting it so they find out for
example if you take roberta as your
teacher and bert as your student that
doesn't really work
and then of course this would also apply
to other things like you know if you
take something like i don't know
big bird and you try to distill it into
a very different type of student like
maybe tiny bert it will probably not
work
but i'm kind of skipping ahead of many
details so i think what i'll do is at
this stage i'll sort of let's take a
step back and ask ourselves like um
you know what what is this knowledge
distillation all about and how does it
work
so the the kind of
cartoon um that we can use is that
we need to find a way
during training to um provide
information to the student
that about the
knowledge that the teacher has acquired
during its own training right so for
example here we've got a teacher
which let's suppose it was already
trained
on some form of like classification so
here you know you've got four classes
to classify maybe different reviews of
food
and so the idea is that we've got
examples like the tacos were okay we
know the ground truth which could be mer
and we also know that the teacher which
has already been trained on this type of
data it will make a prediction for what
it thinks is the most likely
label
or you know class for that particular
example
so the way this works is we during
training
we basically augment the standard
cross-entropy loss that the student has
with an additional loss term which is
called the knowledge distillation loss
and this this additional loss term what
it does is it basically compares
how good are the distribution of
probabilities from the teacher matching
the distribution of probabilities of the
student
and the idea is that you want the
student to somehow mimic uh the teacher
over time
so at the start the t the student
basically knows nothing about the task
it's got it's just kind of randomly
initialized but during training and
through back propagation hopefully then
the student will learn that ah the
teacher is telling me that okay for this
particular set of examples here are the
class distribution well here are the pro
the distribution of class probabilities
i should essentially adapt my own
predictions to kind of match that
and the way that matching is done is
using something called the kl divergence
so the ko divergence is this kind of
like um let's say scary mathematical
thing
but basically what you can see in this
equation here
is it's just taking essentially the
difference of
two
probability distributions p and q and
it's got some logarithms in there to
make it kind of behave nice
but the basic idea is that if you have
these two distributions p and q one for
the student one for the teacher
then we can include this comparison in
the um in the loss
and the thing that we typically do in
the field is we say okay
we're going to include this loss term
and then we're going to essentially have
a weighting where we have the standard
cross entropy loss plus this knowledge
distillation loss
and the way we weight this is usually
with a parameter called alpha so if
alpha is one then we basically switch
off knowledge distillation completely
and if alpha is zero then we completely
square switch off all the signal
coming from the
cross entropy
and you know in practice some kind of
balance between the two is typically
what you're looking for and this is a
hyper parameter that you can optimize
for
okay so we've got these like two loss
terms um and the one thing i haven't
quite mentioned yet is
what is this like this t parameter or
this or this um temperature
so
the reason we have temperature in in the
picture here
is that if we imagine like
what kind of distribution the teacher
probabilities will be
for
my
my examples
what you'll typically find is that if
the teacher is really good because it's
you know a big high-performing model
then those probabilities are going to be
really highly peaked around the true
value
so you can see what i mean if we look up
here
here on the left hand side i have what
is basically
like the ground truth um so we see that
you know meh is is getting all the
probability
and if my if my teacher is a very good
model it will then
assign a very high probability to that
class and very low probability to the
rest and then the student basically
learns nothing new from the ground truth
labels so that doesn't really help us
very much
so what
people have done literature is they say
okay let's try to kind of smoothen out
the distribution of probabilities from
the teacher by using this temperature
parameter
and the temperature parameter is
basically a normalization factor that is
applied to the logits of the teacher so
the idea is that when i'm computing
my probabilities i usually apply a soft
max function to my logics
but before i apply the softmax i can
just divide my logits by a parameter
called t
and then if i control and tweak this t
parameter it will basically kind of
smoothen out
the the probabilities
so you can see in this kind of cartoon
here now that i've set my t
equal to one this might be kind of like
what the teacher typically
would predict
for um for this particular example so
you know may is still highly peaked and
the others have less but if i start
cranking up this t parameter then i'm
going to kind of smoothen out um the
probabilities and assign a greater
weight to the kind of rarer
classes
and the idea is that this t parameter is
again another hyper parameter that we
can tune for
um and as you know as we increase t
the student will then have to kind of
make it a greater effort at trying to
mimic this kind of more flattened
distribution
um and then this you know ultimately may
help us um you know get a kind of more
robust and better performing model
are there any questions at the stage
phillip
yeah there are quite a lot of questions
with this which is awesome um
asked like i think a pretty complex
question maybe we can like quickly
tackle it to give some pointers but he
asked how to distill an encoder decoder
architecture than just an encoder
architecture and how he could like
implement it with the hiking phase
trainer
yeah that's a really good question so
um if we look at this cartoon here um
what you can see is that it's very much
representing like an encoder type setup
because we've got essentially
a classification task so the loss here
for the for the task is um is cross
entropy
now what you could try to do if you're
doing like a sequence to sequence model
the question is basically what should
you change here for this loss term so if
you imagine that i'm doing something
like um i don't know
let's say
maybe translation or summarization
um then
you know what i'm basically trying to do
in in the in the training phase is i'm
trying to basically you know predict
you know what is for example you know
the the one shifted um example in my
text so you know if i've got my
um you know my let's say my long text
and then i want to predict my summary
i've got i've kind of got like a way of
scoring that um using using a particular
loss term
so if you change your loss term to be
whatever it should be for sequence to
sequence tasks
then the rest of the process
will in principle still work although i
personally haven't
distilled any sequences seamless models
so i don't know if it really does work
but i think you should
one of the uh most common questions also
in the chat is like is there any
intuition that you can quickly give on
like
why
distillation um is um better than just
taking a small model and fine tune it on
the data set
yeah great question so
um
the the simple answer is that
um
the the loss term that we're dealing
with is this l student and this is a mix
of two loss functions so it has a
standard cross entropy and it has
this additional knowledge distillation
term from the teacher
so
the the kind of intuition
that one sees in the in the research
literature is that
if we just ignore the teacher entirely
so we switch off this loss term then
we're just doing standard functioning
right
but if we start
introducing this additional loss term
from the teacher and we make it have a
greater weight
than the standard cross entropy
we're actually providing a way
to
give the model
some sort of like additional
um information about the kind of
decision boundaries
um that exist you know in the particular
data set
so what i mean by that is when you just
have very hard targets you know ground
truth you just got one possible class
and nothing else
the model basically has to learn
um over time what these decision
boundaries should look like um and you
know in general these decision
boundaries are like you know kind of
like smooth things in multi-dimensional
space
but we have to learn that from very hard
examples like you know just zeros and
ones everywhere else sorry one and zero
everywhere else
so it takes more steps to learn that
um typically um but if we have a teacher
which has already learned what these
decision boundaries kind of are
then it can actually provide this kind
of smooth information um through this
knowledge distillation loss and so the
kind of intuition is that we're kind of
giving the the student a kind of like
head start in understanding what the
decision boundaries are kind of really
are and it doesn't have to do all the
hard work of learning that just from the
ground truth
but it's a very good question
[Music]
okay so i'm just going to have a quick
look to see if our model is um
still training
okay so it's still in progress
and if we look at the training job um
yeah we can see it's still training so
one of the cool things actually is that
during training
we're actually going to
produce
checkpoints right so as we train we're
going to train for 10 epochs and at each
epoch we're actually going to push
the checkpoint to the hub and so the
cool thing is on the hub is you can kind
of see how your model is doing in real
time
because we've now got this checkpoint
which is essentially the the distilled
student and if you click on metrics
um we'll be able to see now on
tensorboard you know how is the accuracy
doing so you can see for example that at
this stage the accuracy is like around
82
maybe a little bit more and we know that
the teacher
um started off with like 97 accuracy so
you know we at the moment we still are
quite a long way away from the teacher
but hopefully by the end of this
training will be
a fair bit closer
so this is all
basically comes automatically with the
trainer and transformers we have a
tensorboard log kind of
callback which will automatically log
um your training and this then means
that you can inspect um uh you know how
the loss is performing
um and what is the button that lets me
kind of scroll this way yep
okay so now we're like around 87. um the
other thing that's actually kind of fun
is um
in the middle of training you can play
with the widget um for your model
um okay well
you know the demo goes against me
usually you can play with the
model during training
and this is actually kind of fun because
this gives you a way of seeing like
um you know if i give the model some
kind of tricky examples do i see kind of
qualitatively how it gets better
over time
okay so let's just see this is still
training um so yeah let's see are there
any questions um
yeah i think picked out a few questions
but since we have like 30 minutes left
maybe haiko can
get started with um handing out the aws
accounts to everyone to
not be able to like see how the
knowledge distillation model work also
that we can compile it to inferentia and
deploy it to sagemaker
yeah it'd be awesome
and while i think we can answer the
questions in the chat as well
okay
right um so i'm gonna walk you through
i'm also gonna share my screen but the
instructions are also on
philips github repo
actually let me
post the anchored link
so the first link you need to go to is
let's just share my screen
right
so if you're on a philips um
github account and in in this um
workshop github repo
um
this is how you access the aws accounts
and the first thing you need to go to is
this
dashboard.invention eventengine.run
slash login
so i'm going to click that open it in a
new tab
i'm also going to post that link i
phillip posted it already
and what you need here is a um
a team sorry an event hash
that
uh philip have you already shot it or
no let me quickly share so we have since
we are that many people we have two
event hashes so first come first serve
try one out and if you are lucky the one
work if not you you need to use the
other one
yeah exactly
so i'm gonna take this first event hash
and what you do is you just paste it in
here
and then you accept the terms in the
login
and then um you can sign in different
ways we recommend the email one-time
password so if you click that
you need to provide your email address
so here i'm just gonna use my
email address and passcode
and it should take only a few seconds
until you receive
that one-time password in your email
um hiko we have people saying event not
running
oh dumb dumb is that right
that's right i forgot to click a button
yes one second
okay we can see good now so it should
work if not please send a message with
whatever issue you have
perfect works works nice okay nice
so now i got my um uh one-time password
in the email
so with that i can sign in
and you will then see
it's not ready yet
okay
maybe
that one is already
booked out
in that case i'm going to exit the event
i'm going to use the second
hash um
you should see the event name
and then you can
click on aws console up here
and then open aws console
and that should
bring you in
okay
of
course
was
anyone already successful to get to the
aws console
in the dashboard okay yes yes okay me
yes yes console i can access it okay
okay
so the only person who can't access it
is
[Music]
the aws person excellent
well good to hear that people can access
it um
if you can access it already let me then
just scroll down here
um
what you then do is um you can um either
find sage maker in the
recently visited services
um or you can just type it in the search
bar up there just type in sage maker
and then that will
provide a link and once you are in sage
maker
in the sage maker overview
you can click on notebook and then on
notebook instances
if you at that point stop that do not
follow the steps
9 10 and 11
because those would create new notebook
instances but what you should see
in
in your accounts
that there are already four notebook
instances ready for you now because
we're such a large group
um
we
we put two people on one aws account
and
the way this works now is
i wish i could um
log in now
let me try again
[Music]
the idea being
that
there's four notebook instances
and you have not really a way to co
communicate or coordinate which either
with each other
so that means um you will have to open
one of those notebook instances
and see if a kernel session is already
running i think i have screenshots
actually
okay we have we have people um having an
arrow with like the same arrow please
verify your hash code and try it again
maybe like
you could what browser are you using
maybe it's like try to
use an incognito chrome top to really
don't have any like local
local storage cookies or whatever
running
um and then and for for like which of
the four notebooks to open so like i
said like we are since we are pretty
large group we are sharing aws accounts
so you can select one of the notebooks
uh first come first serve and when you
are in jupiter there's like the top with
running and if you see that the notebook
you opened is already running you can
like easily select another one or just
yeah kernel not running what kernel to
use and we are going to use the conda
python 3
kernel but i i will
show you everything in a second
so um yeah you can like i opened it here
in jupyter lab i took some screenshots
if you see already kernel session
running then just use a different
notebook instance
um and then if you see nothing running
then just open up the relevant
um
notebook which is labs like you go into
workshop 4 distillation and acceleration
and then you open up lab 3
aws inferential inference
and then
i used
this kernel but the
python 3
like philip said also works
[Music]
and that's it
i think plus you can check if your
training is done and
while taking a look we are trying to
figure out to help anyone who cannot
access their aws account yet yeah i will
uh
sure so let's um have a look on our
sagemaker job what's happening
okay so we see that the job is completed
and if we then visit our um
our model um on the hub
we've now got a nice model card which
tells us okay this is a fine-tuned
version of this model on this data set
and this is the performance we got
so you can see that here we've managed
to get an accuracy of around 95 percent
which if you remember the teacher
um had an accuracy of 97
so we've only really lost two percent
here um and mini lm is much much smaller
um than roberto large i i can't remember
it's like a factor of 10-ish roughly
maybe it feels correct
yeah it's around 10 times smaller than
the orbital large model
exactly so
um once that model is now being uploaded
to the hub you've also got it available
in a s3 bucket on aws
and so what you can also do is you can
deploy
an endpoint
using the same hugging face estimator
object and this will then basically
create an end point where you can send
requests and it will generate
predictions
but since we're kind of tight on time
i'm not going to go through this you can
just run through this yourself but it's
basically i'm just a couple of lines of
code
and then you'll be able to see through
these logs you know what kind of
latencies
this distilled model is going to
typically get
so shall we switch over now to
inferential
yeah just one more information so i
managed to now log in with the second
event hash so what happens is when you
use the first event hash and try to log
in
then you're
already somehow logged in into the aws
account so if you get that error that
you saw earlier when i screenshot you
need to lock out of this um like log out
with your credentials from aws at all um
that's in the top right there's a lock
out button and then just open again the
aws console
from from this screen here oh you can't
see my screen right now
but um just try to open it again and
then i managed to get into the
aws management console
hope that works
perfect so let's use the last remaining
20 minutes to quickly compile our model
to inferentia and run some awesome
predictions so what we are going to do
or what you need to do to convert your
transformer models to inferentia is to
use aws neuron sdk which is an sdk
created and maintained by aws to compile
models which can then be run on aws
inferentia and aws neuron is
i would say high level kind of similar
to what torch script is doing so you
have your pytorch model
and for tensorflow it's of course
different but like staying with python
you have your pytorch model and you are
tracing it like creating a static craft
from your neural network and
compared to torch script what neuron is
doing is not using the operations which
are in the official python library aws
has created custom operations which are
specifically optimized for the aws
inferential chip which means they are
more
efficient and more faster which helps us
to achieve the super low latency and um
to begin you can like select your kernel
i use the conduct pytorch pi 36 kernel
and the first thing we need to do is to
install torch neuron and some additional
dependencies like transformers datasets
and sagemaker just to make sure that we
have everything installed this could
take some minutes and time and but it
should be
installed afterwards and david yeah it's
it's similar to onyx but
not
i mean it's an accelerator but yes it's
like creating custom or applying casting
custom operation operations
[Music]
okay
i hope the installation won't take
forever can you zoom in a bit yes i can
zoom in a bit
okay
yes mati so you can instead of what we
are doing is compiling our model inside
the notebook instance um with aws neuron
but you could also use sagemaker neo to
create a compilation chop and apply as
instance type target inferentia
and cole asks uh does this work for any
hugging phase model
um
sadly not yet
so
as mentioned
torch neuron on the aws neuron sdk
created custom operations for
specific basically neural network
operations and if you use the model
which has
implemented
operations which aren't yet supported in
torch neuron it could be possible that
you cannot convert yet to aws neuron
and at all four years it's definitely
suitable for any real-time use cases you
have
well that's
nice then
we can retry the installation so if you
have seen an installation issue with
data sets remove it for now
and then reinstall later that could be
possible due to some like
i don't know update we have
released lately
but we have installed our neuron we can
execute or define our model id this is
basically the same model lewis has
distilled in his training but we have
done it in advance so we are already
able to use it and
convert it and what we are then going to
do is basically using transformers with
the from pretrained method to load our
model we apply torch withdrew which
helps us to easier convert our model we
create a dummy input
say that we want to pad it later to 128
sequence links so similar to taut script
aws neuron is not supporting dynamic
shapes meaning the inputs you are
providing to the model always need to be
the shape which you are tracing to
meaning we are tracing now to 128 when
using inference later we also need to
make sure that the inputs we are
providing to the model have the same
shape
and then we are tokenizing our inputs to
create our embeddings and then we are
only need to run torch.trace provide our
hiking phase transformer model our
inputs
and that's basically it and then we will
compile it and at the end we will save
it to a directory
with our tokenizer and our configuration
to make sure we can run in translate
later
from nc about how does like inference on
infringer compare to things like
inference and tpus with respect to
latency and throughput
so i have no
numbers in head how fast transformers
are on tpus for inference but what we
are doing on inferentia and what you can
do in the notebook is we are compiling a
mini lm model which is around 150
megabytes and i'm not sure how many
million parameters and we are achieving
five to six millisecond latency
for 128 sequence length per inferential
core
okay so yeah when when running at the
model you can see that's printing out
some configurations saying okay how much
of our operations can be used and
optimized we are
almost close to 100 which is good
meaning that inferential will later use
the optimized operations to run our
inference
and still
yeah taking some time maybe there's more
questions
yes so marty is um
asked if it should work for other tasks
then sequence classification our example
like question answering yes so it is not
depending on the task you can you only
need to make sure that you load the
model correctly with the correct auto
model class from transformers and to
provide
the correct input for
question answering it's of course
different to what we have with um
sequence classification
okay here we can see
which operations are compiled and
applied and yeah it's done so we have
now compiled our model and we can take a
look it's now instead of 150 megabytes
before it's only 108 megabytes since we
are not only changing the operations
inside the model we are also converting
the float32
um weights to float16 which decreases a
little bit aside with some trade-off in
terms of performance
and then
what next we need to do to like run our
model later on stage maker is to create
an inference pi script in this case we
need to provide a model function and a
predict function this later acts as an
entry point for our request we are
sending to stage maker the model
function is basically the function
yeah called when starting our endpoint
which in this case loads our tokenizer
loads the model similar to what it's
done with torch script
it's basically identical but we are
importing torch neuron instead of torch
talk script and then loading our
configuration for our labels to create
nice outputs and returning it to
the handler which is run behind the
scenes and then we have the predict
function which is used every time we
send a request to our model which first
gets our data and then basically the
output of our model function which is
our model tokenizer and model config and
then the only thing we need to do is
to get our inputs tokenize the inputs to
the
sequence length in this case we saved it
in our model config earlier to 128
run our model
run our embeddings through the model
apply a softmax at the end to basically
get the the highest probability and then
basically create a nice return using
pytorch utilities to get the index of
our label so we can read it and what the
score of it was
and after we have created our inference
pi we can
run the same configuration as lewis as
shown earlier to make sure we have to
write impermission and the right s3
bucket
in our session to
share with stage maker okay what are we
going to do and then basically the last
step we need to do since we are this
time not deploying from s3 or from the
hiking phase hub we have our model
currently stored locally in a temp
directory with our code our inference pi
our tokenizer our configuration json and
the model weights what we then need to
do just to create a model archive which
contains all of those files and upload
it to s3 and then we can use this
artifact as free ui later in our
creation and this can be created not in
the notebook you could also like create
it on your local machine push it to s3
and then deploy the model
just a question philip from dogfield who
says
can you do like batch inference
in this setup with neuron and
inferential and you know do you get kind
of good performance as well
yes so you can definitely do batch
influence but you need to be careful on
how to trace the model so currently we
have created our model or traced our
model with an expected batch size of one
so if you want to do batching you need
to make sure that you are tracing it
correctly and i think since the latest
or the second latest release of aws
neuron it also supports dynamic batching
meaning you can
either have a batch size of one or six
and having like an and then
small time waiting between like the
inference coming in to
get a better performance
of usability basically for your model
but in terms of what the
throughput is i can only refer to the
blog post shared earlier maybe lewis you
can share the blog post again or a guddy
if i saw you also in the workshop um
listening to it maybe share what um
performance results aws has already
achieved with inferentia
there's another question from galena
about when you do this with torch.no
grad does that speed up the prediction
process or maybe why are you doing that
yeah we are doing that just to
let our model know that we are not
calculating any backwards uh
back propagations which
definitely you should
i mean the output is different and i'm
not sure if it accelerates the influence
do you know
i'm not sure about inference but it
definitely uses less memory so maybe
that helps
yeah raj also started saves memory
and
so while we are answering the questions
i already run the cell which is similar
to
the estimator we have seen earlier which
in this case is a model again way we
define our
storage of our model and which
transformers version and python version
as well as the python version we want to
use
and then we can run the dot deploy
method where we define um on which
instance and which instance type we want
to use and when the cell is finished our
model is deployed to stage maker on an
inferential instance and we can start
running some
predictions
and i also have seen that tiana bay has
asked the question
if we have large documents much longer
than the max length what we can do
are you asking about the max length we
have defined with 128
this length can be increased to the max
length of the model in our case it
should be 512 and if you have like still
the documents are longer than this you
have to like split them up into either
multiple documents or you can like test
if maybe the first 512 tokens are enough
to achieve good performance or
if like
the end is more important at the
beginning but you can like split it up
or
just experiment which other parts most
important in it
are there more questions
louise i saw a uh question a while back
which went back to the distillation
which i found interesting i think it was
from sedund if i just can find it again
but it was basically saying the
performance was still good but he saw
the um confidence of the
of the
student model drop so you know while
it's still quite accurate it seems to be
less confident about that
yeah i
i think
i think that's kind of
it might be i would say it's kind of
expected a little bit because
like the
the the student
will generally not mimic the teacher
identically um
because i mean i suppose if you wanted
to
improve the confidence of the student
you could try
increasing this alpha parameter which is
basically the signal from the from the
teacher
and so if the teacher
has a certain confidence distribution
for the classes then increasing the
signal from the teacher will then
typically bias the student
to get better at that
so that would be one way to to try that
so increase the alpha parameter
but it's a subtle question because it's
actually like a two-dimensional problem
you've got temperature as well so it's
kind of like
you could try for example
you know setting the temperature
to one
and then just cranking up alpha that
would probably be the way to
bias it the most
another question now whether the student
can have better accuracy than the
teacher
um
so
in practice yes for reasons i don't
really understand
so there's a famous example in the
distilled paper
um
they distilled
um a small bur architecture from from
burr
and then
they um took that model and they then
um which was basically a pre-trained
kind of a transformer and then they did
this kind of distillation like we did
today on squad so they basically took
again as steel but model and distilled
it on on squad
and um they found that it got better
performance than just training from
scratch on squad and
they don't explain it and then i saw it
in in
in the book um we encountered the same
phenomenon and i i couldn't find a good
answer for this um
except
maybe it's a question of like you should
really do lots of like repeated runs
um of of like training with distillation
and then maybe it's like you know just a
fluctuation
um in your metrics
but yeah it's a it's a funny phenomenon
i've seen and i don't know the answer
and
while you were talking and answering the
questions our model got deployed and we
can now run a request to our model in
this case it's
some movie review basically and
predicted the os class and next the
notebook has basically a snippet which
we could use to
um
evaluate our
um
model again
against the data set since we compiled
it to neuron which is cool and we see a
response but we don't know yet how how
good it performs and for this we need to
install the data sets library you can
like now install it and if you like run
into the issue same as i in the
beginning it's i guess some like python
incompatibility issues so you can like
try to install data sets at the end
again and what we are doing is here is
basically using the data sets library
loading as metric accuracy as we have
done in our fine tuning and knowledge
distillation steps loading our data set
and then creating a helpful method which
basically sends a request to our
endpoint with the um validation
data point and returns the accuracy of
it or the label and then at the end
after we run all of the requests and we
are calculating the
accuracy for our results from our neuron
model against the ground rule from our
data set and as you can see while i was
talking we have sent over 3000 requests
to our model and achieved an accuracy
from 93.89
which is pretty good therefore that we
went from
um
almost 100 milliseconds latency i think
79 milliseconds on the midi lm model
down to
only a few milliseconds
on
the aws inferential and we can also take
a look at a model we included a print
statement which will point you to the
cloudwatch logs and metrics where our
um
or where stagemaker basically stores
our inference
and if we wait a few more
seconds we should see way more data
points than just the one we have here
yes and maybe to summarize it again
since we don't have much time we we went
from
like taking a look at the image we have
our p99 latency which is like one
forward pass through the model for a 128
second length
and we have the accuracy
and the size of the dot basically
represents the model size and as you can
see the roberta large model
achieved the best accuracy with
97 something and is super big and has
around 300 milliseconds of latency then
we distilled it into the mini lm model
which achieves 94 accuracy and is
already a way smaller and then we
compiled it to aws neuron and
inferential which got even more smaller
and more faster and then you
basically get the 52
x improvement in terms of latency by
only lose use losing three percent of of
accuracy which is a a pretty good
trade-off um for basically gaining the
performance and especially for
real-world use cases or real-time use
cases where you might not be able to
wait 300 milliseconds this kind of
techniques can really help you
um going into production and i think a
question i've seen earlier i'm not sure
if we have answered it somebody asked
the performance of the mini lm model
just fine tuning on a data set
and it is
almost as good as the knowledge
distillation part but i think it's
something around 92 percent so two
percent less than what we achieved with
the noise distillation part which is i
think a fair trade-off and we gained two
percent using knowledge distillation and
lost 0.1 percent and which is still 1.8
percent higher than the normal fine
tuning and gained 30
13 times sorry more performance with our
model so we traded basically more
compute to this knowledge distill our
model to gain a small percentage of
accuracy but at the end we gained 13
14 times more latency or lower latency
basically
okay
yeah thanks everyone for for chiming in
if we haven't asked to answer your
question and you're super curious feel
free to to open it in the forum again we
are more than happy to answer all
upcoming questions about knowledge
distillation or aws and sagemaker
and
thanks for tuning in and we will upload
the session to youtube
and yeah the labs are
for
some times after they went available i
think it's like 30 minutes or something
you can like still play around with it
yes thank you everyone and thanks for
these awesome questions it was a really
cool interactive session
thanks everyone
bye bye